東京2020オリンピックが終わってもスポーツの夏はまだまだ終わらない
折り返し地点となる8月9日チームコカコーラがスポーツの楽しさをプラス版する
チームコカコーラプラスワンフェススタートねー
[拍手]
ところで皆様お願いいたします mc を詰めますアルコ&ピースの平子と社会ですお
願いしまーす
ありがとうございましたマーサーの大島由香里ですよろしくお願いしまーす
さして超売れっ子の youtube クリエイターの皆さんですお願いしまーす
[拍手]
ご説明いたしますチームコカコーラプラスワンフェスとは
チームコカコーラが誇る人気 youtube クリエイターし課金肇社長
水たまりボンドフィッシャーズアバンデイズと10日様やのピンチに駆けつけた6人の
有無助っ人軍団でお送りするスペシャルナンバー組となっています皆さんもぜひ
ハッシュタグプラスワンフェスで番組の感想や
応援のツイートをやってくださいちなみに現在はこの第三部はじめ者ちょうど
チャンネルで配信をしています
ご覧の5つのチャンネル横断して配信されますのでぜひ第1部から第5部はですべて
ご覧ください
そして第3部の東海親の皆さん撮影に参加できないので
ミンチギターのううーむ助っ人軍団の皆さん引き続きよろしくお願い致します
で今回も皆さんには5つのチームに分かれてスポーツにちなんだ企画に挑戦して
いただきます
ここで改めて5つのチームのチーム分けご覧いただきますこちら各チームのリーダーは
賦課金さんはじめ者嬢さん
カンタさんシルクロードさん利口さんとなっています
ここまでね様々な競技でぶつかり合ってきましたがそれぞれでちょっと無双した方がい
たりとか言うと印象深い方とかどうでしょ
皆さんでしょとこの海の誰々が印象深いなってありますか
ヒカキンさんどうですかいややっぱり僕ゲームで
ダーマに馬だけだぜん
あってる気はしなかったそうねうーんちょっとダーマーさんの今後のゲームチャンネル
なんかねえ
yoshiko に開設しちゃうかああ
そしてパターゴルフでのでだこさんそうよなんか
うーんうまくいきました今日
そしてルームランナーでのトマトくん
うわーっの爆走無理もでありました
そして様々なハプニングもありましたブーブー退けるクリップが取れるにょちょっと
こっからもね様々な事件起こるかもしれませんがそれは第3一つ
女の近くへまいりましょう車まずは相手を一撃 ko せ
ボクシングっぽとるー
から皆さんにはボクシングの精子達に負けないくらいの壮絶な殴り合いをしてみたかっ
ていますああ
みなさいといいですね実際が栗合うわけではなくてですね
今回はセガのゲームソフト東京2020オリンピック時
オフィシャルビデオゲーム内でのゴム寝具ゲームで対決していただくと
になります
ルールご説明しますチームから1人の代表選出を選出しまして
個人戦トーナメント形式で勝ち上がったチームの勝利となります順位に応じてポイント
get
ポイントなるので頑張ってください
さあそれは各チーム代表選手を選出してくださいまあ凄いんだろうなぁ
新格闘技経験者なんかもいるんですかね
ゲームとはいえこの際郡すごい c ことねさしかに
[音楽]
あもうで組んでるようですよねさあそれではそれぞれ発表していただきたいと思います
まずは比較に知恵分
私日かギヤー
bejean
いけますかもう今日はあのゲームしに来たんで
あー楽しみにゲームだというなるほどはいつか s パターン言ってもここまでの
ゲームでもいい家つけてますからね
今のソップですさせどじゃないか
さあ続きましてはじめしゃちょーチームはどなたでしょう
はいこっこはチャンネルですね僕が行きたいところなんですけども勝ちに行きたいね
駄目だぞ
[拍手]
勝てるアーマーの名前が汚れた瞬間した金さんが手を仰ぎました
中谷ですがちょっとあの決勝打を避け集でしたら
予選で潰しないみたいな家じゃんだ受信はどうでしょうか
山根今自分のチームが兄で5点差なんでこの子ら遺作と殴り飛ばす影響で行った
28待ちしてるなぁ
はついてカーンたチームどなたでしょうか北館でないんですよ
どうぞじゃーん
[音楽]
ブーバー男女なるでしょうか続きまして宿老チームとバカでしょ
うちのチーム
から早くですからー
[拍手]
ブーブーいい
ですよ本当これ何でも印象熱帯やめたんですしまう
ana では今回ははるかが僕箸でやったことないっす
dj
悪い流れを変える挨拶ありますからね
ざっ主催の実行チームとなったでしょうか
て全くんねああ
誰が結構おおぉ
ランナーマラソンでは見事ね市になりました格闘技ボクシングはどうでしょう
やってないですうわぁ
いやーなこんばんはにおいてちょっと1回ジャブジャブをちょっと軽くしてもらって
いいですか
はいあーぞ
nan
ですね隠してるしちゃうんだよすっがあるよ
あれ思ったかの可能性あるなぁ
さあここからですね対戦カードの方を決めていきたいとおもいます
こちら抽選のに行きましょう pou dou dou 私佐賀中戦没を聞かせて
いただきます
はいさあそれではまず対戦カード決めて行きたいと思います人は悲しき名前が出た
チーム
がその枠に入りますしちなみに皆さん心チームとアマル当たりたくないなぁってあり
ますか
玩具や者やん
2こっからの海から見た人だーもに何が起こってるん
then で富るっとねーアイスをさをネスっていただきたいと思いますさあそれでは
はいソジュランスこちらがトーナメそういう風になっているんですが合う者によります
と
うん売りとさんそっかーーーん face が追い出すうよねー
ちょっとここでさっきん
そういう感じですなるほど皆さん入ってどんなありましたねあるいはおいろけわよしっ
開運まずはこちらのないうち1枠目のチームがれ歳出していきたいとおもいます
とありますよ俺いいですねーネオンございます
ドンッ
あれを知る者労働
全然アイフード付行ってる頃しれない多い
[音楽]
んはぁはぁ言いたくないですよねはい
はあああああ
me
wh
none
b 00 gj
me too
[拍手]
ああああああああ勝っ可能です
日クロスああ
ず常田内海カーンた車ありません
wh
ni
1これ済むよねぇねぇこともあるバーン
ここでまず戦ってしまうスポツ星らになるわけですね
俺はなかなか
んじゃねまあまあ勝ち上がればどこかではあたりますからねぇ
[音楽]
ということですこれもですね競技別スタジオで用意されておりますのでここから私たち
mc 3人と協議する方のみ
サブスタジオに移動となります移動しましょう
はいね
ああああああ
全画面が揺れだったらで快感ですよねー
勢い生涯なぁこれはいたじゃん映像馬いますあそこを買ったらいいよいいんじゃない
厳しいねぇ
2日間さんやったことあるだろうし
ダーマさん乗ってるし
やさんだねあそこででも急に723の勝者に家買ったらめっちゃいいねぇ
ありがとう皆様へ詐術ないでみましょう堺さーん
ハーイこちら準備立たないましたもう1回戦から好カードでございます
[音楽]
ああああああ
rar
強そうには見えないじゃないですかあああ
人はねぇ
いやパッチ待ちしておりますけれどもでませんそんなの意気込み聞いてみたいと思い
ます
まずヒカキンさんいかがでしょうかいやもここで買ったらかっこいいなあーいい n
あのーちょっとあの控えてるメンバーに申し訳ないけどこれ実質結晶だぞっ
とってますですはい
グッカーズアンダーアーマーを倒すということでございますけどさぁたいスーダンは
さんどうでしょうか
はいさっきちょっと聞いたんですけど比嘉恵さんこれ
軽くやったことあるって言うんでちょっとこれ部が少し悪いのかなぁと思うんです
けれどもやっぱりたとえ
意地があるんでこっちにも貼っしたいと思います
あるほどぞ
山の日か曲田口試合でございます
さあそちら b ものを始めていきましょうおい
関西もう3出せればが
阿蘇の自分マジやばやばいん
ren ん
見えますいいいいいいいいいいいいいい
ううっうぅううええええええ
read me
wh
none
car はちきん注1 rar
人になりたいはっはっは
ああああああああああああああ
1月聖書種ちゃんとソードしてるもカード部分からねんけど
当然ほど素敵だしますスピーカーじゃないでしょうかあああああ
rar
me
ええええええ
5日前 nani
me
ran ん
[拍手]
そこリンチか頑張り
me
ああああああ
goo
[拍手]
ん
me
wh
ああああああ
ん
下げる
wand
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
nome です
君マジかー
がきましたんじゃあまだ1回戦ねあぶレター
きてしまったのはこれぐらい
決まりましたねこれはなかった2こちら
スーパーすごいどっちが勝つとなった
お見事ですねー
barena
素晴らしい not ないぞって怒らねえようーさーさ一ヶ月はいかがでしたか
いや最後の必殺技なんか左に出てて打ってみながら完投を押せたらね
ちょうどダーマがパンチ大仕掛けから彼
入っていません
ということで優勝ですかね a
はが話してると
いらっしゃったからね
ちょっと鼻さーん縮毛
結構あのチャンバー芸術科アートですけど最後のアーちゃんため必殺パンチに撃ち抜か
れてて全然ヌー
さあということでヒカキンチームの勝利ということで純真してるだけ
[拍手]
さあそういうことで2回戦は
止まったり簡単でございますね俺も楽しみだからですね
いえる
goo 2
さあということで課金チームがここで勝利ということで感謝だりましたん
eo 大集合ぐらいの盛り上がりません
ん
ね旦那さんもチョコ要所要所でねキャリイカウンターいるとはやんですけどないのに姉
だけ見えてきれいな kof 室
ここですかちんさん持っちゃうんじゃないのかなぁ
x タイプ崎課金の図式になってまいりましたが
そう続いてないんですけどでしょうかねファン準備たと思ったよです
酒井さんもうちょっとですからねしました酒井さんが後世に口を出しまあし下さい
よろしくにゃですねうん
そして次が405ワークはーい
ポリー区賃貸ツアー3勝ちということですはいさん酒井さんの派遣を直したようですよ
これ構成として1回リハやった方がいいんじゃない
いらっしゃいませんさんですよろしくお願い致します
ん
さあ第3試合でございますけれどもとまた分隊カンタさんでございますううーん
さあまずは簡単さ意気込みいかがでしょうよさっきの子が盛り上がりすぎてもう予選
みたいなメンバーである
ちょっと地方予選カングー s けれども是非頑張ってください
佐藤まとめいかがでしょうパッチ方4選は地方予選に面白そあざっしてルアーなーるほ
dadad 素晴らしいクロスしてまいりましょう
ああいう書くでしょ
何て言ったんだけどさぁ例えば家市場
すごいさ勝てば決勝です
[音楽]
そうはいってもなんどかこちらのケースがあります
父がこれねー
すげー役
はっはっは ani
ああああああ
て換算される
重いなぁあ yandere
大隣接第4次5間所わー
あっ注意だな
ちょいなーさー勝てば決勝の戦いとの力を体感ファースト対決そうそうしたから積極性
入らないこと
パンチパンチ一は
wh
os ok 単発 ok
めっちゃいい車ちょっと見せて
ああああああ
where
じゃってるよ
w どっち
ああああああ
あああああ
言ってはいられない
me
[拍手]
ああああああ
さあ100ございます
nim ならコレ
ああああああ
湯だけな
いらっしゃいません
いいいいいいいいいい
rar
ああああああ
me
ni
ああああああ
[拍手]
wh
教材
あああああ
[拍手]
nani
ああああああ
[拍手]
て r
あって me
[拍手]
me
ああああああ
dare ni
me
ああああああ
[拍手]
who ん
me
n ame
ああああああ
gan ban
たてないん
me
ni
サボっ
買ってろーっ
[拍手]
rar
goo
いや良かったかすごいわー
熱い試合でしたの本日が良かった良かった
さあ今度さん見事決勝進出ですいやとんでもなく立ち上がってきたのでもうなんかこう
買ったですね
やられるんじゃないかという
ね一発がある世界なんでん
桜区宿こんなとこ藤井だったね何度に立ち上がりましょう
もうちょっと頑張ったんすけどん
やっぱ拡散違ってほしいシーンもありました素晴らしいナイスファイトでございました
あなたのあった
いやすごい素晴らしかったです店で見ろ遂げられる
ぐらいですねっじゃあ3白いホラー
いよう0
平和名勝負数えるがその1ですでも
デカンタチーム覇者の結晶フードダウンですねこうなるぞ
俺だぁ触れ良いよ
高山たり道具類の場所はぁっはぁっはぁっ
煽りては倒れても起き上がると元くんの連打の速さはちょっと気持ちあるんですけどね
ありがとうございます
安のミューズアップの先生で練習しているみんな
は他のゲームとかでもレンズする気があるのかなぁ
[拍手]
[音楽]
元の勝因が高いでしたねもうなるとそっか
シルクチームと非課金チームの獣愛所の
満たずあさんと春できるさあを
はいネットで繋がった日ないんですね酒井さんお願いします
はいこちらは勝てば決勝進出の対決でございます
シルクチームハル君対比書ヒカキンさんでございます
さあハル君どうでしょうかいやちょっと正直ひっかけ遺産を殴るっていうのがそんなん
んですけど負けまくっちゃったエフェクターとが分ば jr 鍋
中谷後輩とでもう浮かぶなるに行こうからしいも背を超え一切と思いますなるほどを
目指すよね
さあ一確認さん1回戦勝っておりますけれどもそうですねあのダーマの顎を砕いている
まあまあ次決勝しか見てないんだよならーの思い切っ
いきたいとおもいますさぁスタートしてまいりましょう
思いもするよ
小座間してる
俺なんだ俺からアドバイス時差開店が返信をし
食べて社会に参加するしてろよ
オズ予報あげああ
対応 os
me
いや推す動きやすいからございません
さあ第1番を背負った
dj dai
re re re re
re
re のって o
ben ああああ
me
どうぞ
tsuji
ani
美味しくています
[拍手]
ああああああ
mar
wh
ああああああ
4 chome
ございました
富州原ございません
旦那ちょっと申請しているけどこの浦和に見る
終わらないです
いやーん
いいいいいい
[拍手]
ああああああ
lenore
[拍手]
ni
me
ani
ああああああ
関西だっていたからっています
a だイェイ
ねー
kokoro ni
toranoana
ございません
rar ん
ああああああん
konoha
[拍手]
ああああああ
goo
rar
none
ああああああ
[拍手]
dj ん
nan
[拍手]
dj ます
torejk
[拍手]
いけないん
ああああああ
ちょっつー
rar
暗くなってからは
盛り関与しながら撮っちゃったかなと
これはもう興奮しているときになれます
ちょっと待ってきますよねのちゃんとめ
うわぁこれが続けるって言うんですよ
ああああああ
goo
[拍手]
というかん
うで埋まっていたら
さあ鍵さんいかがでしたかいややっぱりだーまたをしているだけあって自信ありますよ
ねはっはい
優勝までで駆け上がっていただきたいと思いますあとは感動を倒す咲く春の花さんが
決勝で待ってください
さあかあったですね大を敷き woody チキンヌードル
3がの継承指数ございましたありがとうございます
[拍手]
やべぇ消防四郎室れ
ここで課金さんが決勝に勝ち上がっております
んとうーんのでしょうか
いう方ですねこれ皆さんどうでしょどっちいきそうすかねぇ
妻回路を迎えるよう
3ターンし動かしたくなかってるんだよ久住回決めてるそれは本来
コマンドまで入力精度が高いお酢はの激アツ演出ね
あっああぁああ
バッハ着せると一緒だもんであるよ
ああ
なったんですよ
野党なので背負うような尻腰
まあ頃トレばっかりは分かりませんかねひとみさん結構もらっておりますからね
彼だよねー心配でしたね確かにもらっちゃった
カウンターで体は感が3回あったからね
小田急からガードも覚えてきた感じが海が見て取れたからわかんないよねれてキャーな
ため日笠が戦った後ろで見てたからどうなの
あとはヒカキンさんのレンダーズカレーもありますよねアンチャー
第二の手技や要因です
連戦になるのでうーん一番情報は多いんだけどヒカキンさんが出してる情報だしてるん
確かに上がってるから
それでこんだけですねちゃんとポイント差もつけられてるんだから周囲の強い本当に
たちがここで優勝するとでもだいぶグット
そっかもう2000立つことを言ったポイント数にはなりますガーナ戻しさあ現在
あ
酒井がでしゃばってヒカキンさんにアドバイスを送ってるんだあああ
することなんですね
こういうことなんですね
一度みんなを集めて
様々な艶とについての土井そしていん
んすみません
ber
none
あんなん
これではい
高いさーん
はいはーい
さあそういうことで決勝戦やってまいりました
決勝で戦うのはひかちんさんと患者さんでございます
頑張ってさあまずヒカキンさん決勝まで来ました
山奥に解かってるんだようん
これはみどあることは3度あるということでなる感じます
試合数も多い計10多いということになりますね
サーカさんいかがでしょう先ほどの試合を
ダーマ君と相談しながら3ダメだよなんでくるチームとそうだセコンドに付いてるん
ですね深く様がアッパーをどう対策するか
7ですねってきたんでこわっ
あってほしい結局上下ありますねすごい
にホームにしたという
ですよさあそれでは決勝さえまいりましょう
まーす
f 1町2村目たかなぁ
なんということだろう
この措置がいますからねこれだけ
うわっこれか笑おう
なんか宇宙へ4月
ano koro koro ni
熱唱千里第一なんだ
ほぼ互角じゃん
素晴らしいレベルがたまらん
やはりソロ
me
てか図柄をゆかりんじゃー
三ツ井またてていく間たじゃんいっ
[拍手]
ani
ああああああ
ん
です足のちゃんと使うてください
voodoo 1
いやーいいいい
me
アレやからいつのシャブがー
rar
ん
簡単です教え
none
ああああああ
作成得意の右アッパーが意味エリアくださ強い右アッパーが率セルカ
[拍手]
収集し頭じゃない
持っていた
ぬあああーーーーああ
wh
re no
面白くなる
大きいのビデオ4レースできましたよね
ああああああ
rar
are you do
9 h
ハウスたようだねぇ
ああああああ
ちょっとレベルが高いさああああああ
sade ん
car
[拍手]
剣6
ああああああ
の方から
rar
ああああああ
まだ何か入って
wa ん
acer 首の cesar
ああああああ
[拍手]
wh
he
ん
素晴らしい脚を使った気が
pr
[拍手]
me
ああああああ
rar
あって行くん
ああああああ
[拍手]
めちゃくちゃいい試合いやぁああああああ患者様ですか女性ですよねーめっちゃめちゃ
せたってました
すごい奴にある笹井空さん惜しくも敗れてしまいましたけれどもほとんど合格なって
いるとあの必殺なアッパーせてね僕にちょっと緩んでしまった後しろねまーす
まず雑貨逆転されるとはと思って
優勝はカンタさんでございましたお見事でございます
ああああああ
もうこれぞこれぱってカーリーヘアー
[拍手]
amaran
ございますねチャオ白ですけれど
そうそう耳元カウンタ遺産がよね1もう一人ましたけどいかがですか
チームの描写は振ってくれましたねぇプレイしましたよね
小さくいけるかもしれねぇって言っていったんですよねこれ
うーん本当にやってくれたんだよ
10回てきたしっかりもみようと思いますあぁじゃあ自信あったのかなぁ
広く罰よねー
源氏塗装その宿も読めてしまいましたねぇ
てればとてもいい試合運極がスムージーをたエアフロー買ったんでさすがなってみまし
た
息があるんですけどほいあの感とさんが車屋まいんだかダーマさんからせ
なったからって田代にだかチーム同士で協力するのはアリだったらこれどうなのかなと
頑張ってたと思うけどみやさん俺になりましたよ
tue jan
me
ん
色々やってるんですか
me
toranoana
アクセスありがとうございます
さあ館た座を見事な優勝だったんですがあの何やらちょっとセコンドからアドバイスを
受けたということなんですけど
どんってアドバイスだったんでしょうかそうですねらーまあ3人いろいろそのアッパー
への対策方向話を動かせっていうのを引いて足思います
とにかく芦生ございました本当のせ
寝ござ
素晴らしいを以上で4ターン
そうポイントが入ってみましょう1位の間たチーム200ポイン
1日50分経営者について0ポイント
ふーん
例は大きいですよも雪よ僕らすいいですね
はいは現在の順位
ねぇライフ4ポイントの順位です1月課金しね押印というのは爺社長チーム250
ポイント三遊間たチームで250本よろです
そして4位狩り空チーム180個5鯉がしうち70ポイント
アガールって言います
ファンとチームのこの100ポイントでさーんに習うどちら緑なんですねおるー
アイフォーレ vd ましたはじめしゃちょー地同じもらっております
まあまあだまだどのチームも狙える位置にいますからね
主力はギリギリですああもうちょっとで晦日すっ夏祭りですけどでもこれはちょっと前
たての可能性ありますから
まぁちょっとページ開始もいいっていう可能性も
そう夏こっから見てるッ
ということで続いた客にまいりましょう続いてまぁ左京
しかも自分はん誰だチーム対抗カラーカーボン
クシーっ
[拍手]
re 4れる
これ綺麗ですよね
もう一体あのゼロから聞いたか切れないんですって
いやほんと素晴らしいでしょ hey
女の闘いが続いておりますさあということで続いての企画にまいりましょう
通じては最強の力自慢は誰だ
チーム対抗瓦割りバサー
[音楽]
me
この企画はチームの代表者1名が瓦割りに挑戦してその枚数を競い合い住民に応じて
ポイント get できるというふうになっておりますジャンポイント1位が100
ポイント
兄が50ポイント3位が25位と4位が10ポイント再開はゼロポイントとなってい
ますねぇ
さあそれでは各チーム代表を選出して下さいお願いします
さあまずは1金チームなぜで課金さんなんでしょうね
me
re
絶対そうだ
とって悪いですからパワー今日はですよね反わぁ
に暮らすま技術もレート洗いますけれども
ブーブーを知るチーム絶対特徴 here ビーバーレディまーぬーほど話し合いをし
ておりますよあれ
ran ん
がよろしいでしょうかまずはし課金チーム
どなたでしょうか
もちろんで書くんですよ h
uh
うんそうかまあ140キロありますしその頬ライブの帰り機だと思われてると思うんで
その力で全部込めて割れないと思いますようわぁ
怪力ですからと言わないんですね
[音楽]
県警はしてると思う何でも終わっちゃいますもう4年前はの笑っちゃうくらいってこと
でいいんですよねもうちょい覚えますじゃないなぁ
ありがとうするんですけれどもんさーついて肇社長はこのチームどちらでしょうか
はい始めた包みから僕が言うと大
シャー州自らなるほどどうでしょうこういうなんか力け
まあ技術も伴いますけども自信はありますかからて習っていたことがありますようん
た専売が怖くて一週間やめたんですけどねぇー
でもなんとなくのこの方的なものは方はこういうだけ行ったことあります
二点画面こういうのだけ素人ですけど
でもまぁ短くとも経験しちゃうんですね続きまして館たチーム
はい僕らのチームはな方が行きません
安全パワーそういうそうだいや僕もまあ120キロあるしな
リーチもあるんでん襲っ影が銀さんだけには負けたくないだろう
あああ
20キロ甘く見ちゃダメでああ
rar 着実な形状でせいぜい
する
なぜん本郷パワーされているぞーなるでしょうかさあそしてここへ買っておくタイ
シルクロードチームとなターンをばボビありますわー
やったことないんだが悪い
やったことあるスプーンああああああ
ブーブーっと市販本
他に遭わされましたが1週間で辞めたりとかしてないんだよねぇー
ちょっと楽しみな気が私ですよは変わらないしはこのね
いたわりなんかもちょっとねそれはやってなかったんですよ
さあ
今までの流れを見るに行ってない人の方がちょっと強そう確かになんか者からては行っ
たことあるけど破ったことはない
何度ちょうどいいバランスちょうどよバダある売ってるんじゃないかな
ん
それでは準備の方はいんだっ
こちらはなんとこのスタジオでですると思いますので3倍お願いしますよろしく
ラー従来よりシルフチームからじゃああー小シルクロードさを愛します
ああああああああいいいい
nome
玉貞兼車道この恋自信ありそうする列車には強いと思う
イーラグローブをつけて会えてがだけ気を付けて下さい
そう
グローバー初めてな問題であれば経験者である主力されグローブなど要らないん
でしょうが
ここは公平を期すためにこんな子ルールでまずでいただきたいと思います
学生時代のあだ名が医師の拳
yeah
マジスパはめっちゃ奥東ですちゃってたら
東京なんとしたんです
いいじゃないと知っていたんですね
マジやっている
ああああああ
さあ気合の声だししながら持ってい
none
[音楽]
さあ
それでは参りましょうまず1人目
シルクの調査んですよね全部ダーワー
ご意見をお願いいたしますそれ
昨日
ぴょんっ
[拍手]
me
hey ナンバーよるとません w
ec 6 e 7位のそりなんで13万
me
特区の保護力まいりましょう
そういうちょっと空想の表情もう僕前20年あってるんですよ
これフォトマークサッカーのダンスりましたね少しミスっ
たーーーすげーいやこれでは触れ悟空のプレッシャーにオナってる状態ですゾーン
居住そうそうでしょ1
オールございます
4ギャザー
さあそれ様はスタンバイと行いましたこれすごい術
それじゃなく子なんてねーよわれ
うーん
[音楽]
第8位の陸王チームもたくさんお願いしますございます
てもらっています
そっかここは経験者なんですねー
てショットにあつきながら余裕の表情
[音楽]
いけそうな感じするな体制は13枚で騒いでるんじゃねーなー
このスタジオの床事俺が植わってやるなん
そのように語っていらっしゃいました食べてないんですよ
カンはカンだよね
3ございます
小指が入らないほど巨大な拳を立ち去れ
優雅
象しました二弾保ち合いの声だししながら
を得ますね
c でしょう加えます
それでは参りましょう2人目
元木さんの挑戦ですお願いいたします
はい
re ko re
ん
どうぞ
同じですしねぇ
car
[音楽]
ハード ana
末成すごいでも下半身を使った終わり方でしたねそれこそ自分の体重をするかねぇ
ねなんかまっすぐ縦に力を伝えなきゃいけないらしい
これきっと待っちゃうん
でもシルクと僕と馬方は動画で企画としてやったことがあろう他のチームとはちょっと
平等に戦いたいんでそこはねうわああああああ
やめでとうございます
それとやっぱり指導と
となんかやんもしれません
わざとお嬢た柴千春の考えられないね
素晴らしいん前の思い出
ずうずうはいそういう傾向でしたぁー
jr
感じはそうですねー
スポット h セッティングができたようです
thursday
サンタチームんだほさんいたしますよ
いきそうだ
どうなるんだよ打ち合わせに行っ
もう本当に極真の選手の計画です
ニャー
あれめちゃくちゃ見てますが生マーしてるんじゃ
対数像を出ると思う
はぁ
しずかんでる言葉を交わさないでもこれはねー
本当に怒ってるのは一人飛ばされた肇社長じゃないですかね
敬遠された後でねなるほどありますねこれから打たないと思っているんだろう
その光の一振りでありますから
じゃあ浜じゃないですねええええ
バッハ
わーわーこれは気合の声だしながらお願いします
さあそれは山林長柄町山です
ひなおさんお願いいたしますすぐ不起訴
んあすこね
お願いします
さあ
t
ああああああ
ねぇごめーん
泣けちゃって行っちゃってるねーっイヤッハーフっぽくなったら馬有
110,000
goo
0カラー何やったんだけどなぁ
車でながらだあれがここで拿捕さんが手こきんさを睨んでいた vtr リプレイで
見るカラー
荒原アーロン
歩いハートで大誤算の挑戦
11枚とん
いうことになりましたん
ちょっとやっぱりパワーに食べちゃったのかな
ない銃を乗せればとよ
入ってたのですがあまりプラスは技術は部分
津軽んですねいや位の部分があるんでしょうねぇ
さあ世界に ok でしょうか iphone たに続いては肇社長チーム肇社長
前でお願いしますじゃあな
サイバー社長を読めないですけどさーんっ
経験したことがあるんですよねこれ
1週間ほど大
ここになってましたん
あー最近水のねぇおっ
1週間で空手道場逃げ出した男が何枚破ることができるのくんファン数は
今13ですもはいずう後は行きたいですよ
融合
男の体の大きさを生かしてしならせてあぁそっちの老齢
ね
博文
してい
弱そうだけどはあああ
葉っぱができますね
お安いということが良かった
染め今
想像はここで近づい感じ見せたらうーん
取り付け動画をしならせて分けられない
声だししながらいきましょう
car
cesar
好きリクエストぺーろぱ沿い
saas 振り具合を大きい見た上ではこれは少しダメそうだが入ってるんでしょうね
さあそれでは4人目味目社長の挑戦です
お願いいたします
いきます
[拍手]
11 a
car
[拍手]
ますね
しかし13雷には惜しくもとの数
死亡ちょっと通っておけばよかったら
石坂よな
感覚的にはいかがですかうまいことは行きました
やっぱり最後なんか力のミートと言いますか
なんかちょっとズレてた気がしましたんだろう
今のところトップは13枚同率で2組が並んでいます
ここでで課金さんが13を超えると非課金チーム結構な独走状態に戻ってしまいますね
はい明石ください
ちなみに好物はなんでしょうか
bouvet てる兄ピューッやっぱりいやいいですねう一応1個5 k
new 3本飲むとかではないんですけど生クリーム食って食ってですよ
ああ
[音楽]
voodoo
性殖力をパワーに変えることができるのでしょうか
尾崎だろうわー
wh
単独1位に躍り出るには14枚を割らなければなりません
作った
響くさあその体重は140キロんやー
箸でが来ないすかいい
足が32cm
b
nba のムトンボでも36ダメだなうん
もっと30日操縦性がやだから一人だけするか違うんだ you can
私に恋ぐふぁいないですねクラーなるほど
ああうん
規格外のパンパンですよね事務所森林
ない
元入ったいろいろじゃんけんうわぁ
詰めてれた形になりますよ楽しめゲソ
一青い瞳で俺はそういうのは横からい足
贅沢は言いませんなのではから台北の僕らじゃなくちゃんとやって下さいだそうです
nerf 杯いけますしますはいちょっとピンチになりますよねええ
1くださいあの半分のタイム体重繁忙パー
ほど中56は呼ばれたんであー政策は言わないつもりいたんですけどまぁこの真ん中
からでも体重のねはい
やべるって言うんです
エアーいいですね
naa いけなくてクレスのパフェスイッチ姿を描いちまってます
排気あの声だしながらいいよ
4人分ブームうわぁそれでは
みましょうねちょっと前だと低いの日
あっはい読みきりましょうじゃないさあそれでは5人目の挑戦で課金の挑戦でござい
ますっ
お願いいたします
hey
[拍手]
me her
大丈夫使うんで大丈夫ですか
ん
110,000円
dare ni
なぜ後で全然じゃあ目よりぽとちんドって知ってる
ですね
[音楽]
6人中およびてる始めちゃうよ痛い12倍ぐらいあるのに同じ前寿しくれそうですよ
ハープて行っちゃっちゃー
ここで改めましてもなおさんとで課金さんのにらみ合いもう一度いい
養育なったということで
イレブンの2人の子ら以外がございません
サージとでで課金さんの挑戦は11枚とん
いましたこれなら美マンちゃったんだわー
市が同率1位はシルクチームそしてリクオチームとうえええ
100ポイント入るんですね
ん
愛媛にとって鼻口はああああ
ねぇそうも頭を守るクソ
生駒でしたとようやく撮れたのは嬉しかったですねぇ
このお米ですよまあちょっとリーダーぷができたかなと思うここから音は見せるところ
あると思うよこれ取れなかったら炎上案件でしたけど
なんかホントにですか
そして同率にが非課金チーム肇社長チーム館等
うん
いうことになり嬉しいわー
に悲鳴はだけができ一緒に付いたよ
これを所の経験者の元木さんもすごかったですね13万
あまり勝ち誇らないですよねシーズンヌーカ
いやちょっと始めて今ゲームに参加できたんで取り purity 貢献できたかな
ブーバーただ本当に普通にうれしかったというんですね
えっと獲得ポイント整理していこうと思うんですが
ジーニーは者っぽい入り3位
3位同率3のいうことで25ポイントなるのでこれなんですねあー
一家ピンチームが25ポイント肇社長チーム25ポイント関多治見25ポイント等に
シルクロードチーム100ポイントリコーチームをやっぽいということになりました
これで合計得点がどう変わっているのでしょうとが現在集計中でございます
[音楽]
ブービーいいと言うと違う見込む
体質の方雷ございます
税収9しておりますやっぱ技術もともらうんだね
うーん
餅が大事なんですねやっぱりない
和田肇社長が凄いのかもしれないしねこれ
たぶんそうすね
ポイントでの十字水がスカー t チーム3月参上森どうぞ
a 200はじめポイントそして最後館等
道立ですねカンタチーム肇社長同率3位で275号イントロして鯉が知るチームでした
金無くなっちゃうせねやってますねー
金近づいてきましたん
俺も楽しみでございますということで皆さん
今回の配信いかがだったでしょうか
どういう船活躍まさかの活躍もになりましたけれども
俺ここシルク様一番売れそうですねようやくですねえじゃあ全然違いますね32さっき
までもうちょい
よかっアンダーしつつ今で100点取っちゃいはそろそろもっと褒めてほしい
んで込めてましたぜベイございますよね
チームもヒカキンさんの背中が見えてきましたかねそうです
嬉しいでもあのさっきゲームに出たことで喜んでたんでなんかちょっとごめんなさい
って言うんですね
when you do
そしてに行けるヒカキンチームしかしちょっと
聖なるまで気配後感じられてきたんじゃないですかこう言う
でっすねちょっと怖いポイント差なんてひっくり返らないようにしたいんですけど
ここまででも0ポイントみたいのがほぼなくねああああそれをしてるんで
3人でうまくこの後
おねさばいていけばハインいけるんじゃないかと思うんだよ今は独走していきたいと
おもいます
うーんさあそして肇社長も
11枚目毎にフリーだんじゃないかと言われる中でねなんとか倒立で追いつきましたが
はいまだ全然では123員がすごい競ってるんでまだ全然逆転できるもちろん
てるね引き続き皆で頑張ってきたいと思います外されたんですよ
はそして感謝チームなもさん
あので課金さんへの睨みを利かしたあの様を t シャツにしないかというかん
れあし欲しいがそれを通っ
音といけませんよねーそれで打った
愛というわけでこちらのチャンネルのアイシンは以上となります第三部の感想もぜひ
ハッシュタグプラスワンフェスでどんどんつぶやいてください
第4部はアバンティーズのチャンネルで18時からプレリア公開ですぜひ第4部以降も
ご覧ください
さあというわけで今回もご視聴ありがとうございましたございましたーーー
[拍手]